now i have josh allen and kyler murray
in my poker league and i've
offered i offered josh allen and zach
ertz
okay okay um josh allen's put up big
numbers first
for jonathan taylor and kareem hunt
um nope i wouldn't do that either okay i
offered josh allen
zack ertz and the buccaneers defense
for jonathan taylor tyree kill and the
steelers defense
i wouldn't do that either josh allen has
it's the zac er 70 but josh allen has
more points double the points
than what tyreke hill and jonathan
taylor
got yes but who are you the points in
the
that you're trying to get tom brady okay
josh allen upgrade over tom brady
josh allen is like gonna be the number
could wind up being the number one
fantasy football quarterback in 2020
are you kidding me but you're trying to
get two starting running backs in return
well one and a receiver and zach ertz i
know right now has got
nothing going for him but the guys had
100 catches last year i mean it's not
like he's gonna be
zero and i've gotten
like you're crazy i'm not that's not
crazy josh allen in my league is 80
points over two weeks
most of any quarterback
i mean i i i honestly thought that was
the better of the two quarterbacks to
offer than kyler murray and josh allen
uh honestly john adams looked good for
two weeks josh
all right let me turn to a guy that uh
knows how to make a trade or at least uh
make a trade as if
what's today's date september 22nd okay
he offers date uh
like a trades to people on today as if
they were born on uh september 21st
he's sports illustrated fantasy expert
michael fabiano how are you fabs
uh i'm good my brother i don't know if
that statement is all together true
oh you're in a hall of fame i'm not so
at least uh you're you're joining us
you're in the hall of fame in my book my
friend all right fabs thank you for that
i appreciate it am i crazy is j i i i
were the trades i just mentioned totally
insane or
at least in the realm of under uh
understandable
here or no you know you know rich uh
you're you're trying to sell high on
josh allen he played two bad teams
um you know your squad and then and then
miami
he's great but jonathan taylor's value
is on another level right now the only
quarterback you're going to
you're going to probably be able to
trade to get jonathan taylor
is going to be one of the two top guys
lamar jackson or patrick holmes that's
how out of this world
jonathan taylor's value is right now
because he's the true featured back
after week one nahin hines
got eight targets and a couple of goal
line opportunities and we're thinking oh
well
taylor will be the guy but he's going to
mix in nahim heinz as well there frank
reich didn't even happen i mean
heinz was on a milk cart this past week
jonathan taylor's value
is right up there i'm not saying he's
with for example mccaffrey when he's
healthy or saquon when he's healthy
or zeke but he's real close man he is
very close people who drafted jonathan
taylor
are holding on to him with a death grip
because he is going to be a league
winner
okay so then obviously um you know
i'm willing to trade even kyler murray
too i mean because i had saquon and i i
obviously need a running back right now
so for everybody out there right now
that lost saquon
for the season what's your advice
figuring out obviously you don't know
what everybody's waiver wire looks like
but you can probably guess
what would you do right if what what is
your advice michael faviano to anybody
who's just lost
saquon and fantasy football well you
know that there's no replacing
saquon or cmc but mike davis has got to
be the top target
off the waiver wire this week the
running back position last week
eight targets eight catches we've seen
some flashes from him in the past he's a
veteran running back
and we know that he is going to be the
guy in carolina right now
when you look at the numbers too i get
it davis is not mccaffrey but
over the last year and two weeks of the
nfl
uh i mean 25.1 touches per game
christian mccaffrey leads all running
backs
they want to run the football and davis
is a guy who maybe for the next month
plus
will be the bell cow for carolina and
at worst he's going to have fleck
starter value because of the volume that
he's going to receive in that offense
jerick mckinnon is another player that
should be added off the waiver wire big
time
this week where he most hurt i mean boy
the niners just got
absolutely decimated with injuries kevin
coleman out as well
so suddenly mckinnon is a potential rb2
against the giants who
have an awful defense as well and
mckinnon's been very good over the first
two weeks he's averaging
over three fantasy points a touch now he
hasn't had a lot of touches
but he's gotten into the end zone a
couple of times so mckinnon worth a look
joshua kelly in los angeles he had 23
carries this past week against the
chiefs
he's fifth in carries among running
backs he's tied for 13th in touches per
game
and he's in a backfield with austin
necklace he's basically come in
and filled somewhat of that melvin
gordon roll so joshua kelly also
worth a look in new york's backfield i
mean i wouldn't be surprised if devonta
freeman's there at some point or lamar
miller they have to go out and do
something but right now
it's wayne gallman and dion lewis i
think wayne galman will be the starter
he'll be the
early down back uh dion lewis is more of
a third down back a guy they're going to
utilize in passing situations
you're not going to find much help there
in that giants backfield from a fantasy
standpoint
daryl henderson's out there as well but
that los angeles backfield for the rams
i feel like every single week could end
up being a different dude week one it
was malcolm brown
this past week it was daryl henderson
cam akers is banged up he's got the rib
injury
so it's really hard to decipher i'll
tell you this this has been
and obviously we're only two weeks this
has been the most difficult
season that i can remember as a fantasy
analyst to try and figure out some of
these backfield situations
well baltimore washington it's been
unbelievably difficult well in terms of
that i mean obviously the the the era of
the bell cow uh
is over and in baltimore in general i
mean like
you know when their fullback scored it's
just like how many eligible receivers
does baltimore have
for lamar to throw to you know i mean
it's it just
it just seems like they're coming out
from everywhere michael fabiano of
sports illustrated here on the rich
eisen show and we do miss you at the nfl
media group brother
um let me do i miss you guys too right
no so
let's be right back at you so uh
shouldn't though someone who's lost
saquon take
someone from his team because mike davis
might get you through a month
but don't you need somebody for for the
long run it's not like mccaffrey's out
for the season shouldn't you take
somebody from the giants
on a waiver wire rich i don't believe in
either one of the backs that they have
right now
i mean that's the issue and also keep
this in mind the giant's defense
is bad i mean really bad what does that
mean for game script
maybe it's more dion lewis in the second
half of games as the giants try to
erase deficits right because he's going
to be the past catching option
it's going to be a committee i'd go
after gauman again but i'd rather have
four to six weeks of mike davis knowing
that he is going to get the majority of
the touches in his backfield
and then who knows who else might pop up
on the waiver wire because we've had so
many
injuries over the first couple of weeks
you just got to keep tabs on that and
then also
i feel like most people probably have
another running back maybe two that they
can plug into a flex position
uh moving forward here without cmc you
can't replace him
you can't replace saquon barkley so
you're going to be playing the matchups
a lot of the time
and we've got a lot of these backfield
committees right in baltimore marking or
jk dobbins both have value in buffalo
zach moss
devin singletary both have value detroit
my goodness gracious that thing
is an absolute headache but i'd rather
get the guaranteed touches for four to
six weeks
from mike davis than try to figure out
who the heck's going to get the ball in
new york on a week-to-week basis between
gaumin uh and dion lewis and again
i mean the giants could end up signing
somebody too and i wouldn't be surprised
if they did so
that could muddy that situation even
further a couple more minutes left with
you sir
uh michael faviano sports illustrated um
would you cut brees or brady in for
derek carr
today would you do that no i i wouldn't
do that
car had a tremendous game last time but
he's looking good i mean
he's efficient and he's dealing and uh
and he's definitely available i imagine
in both in many leagues right now
sitting out you know what though there's
other quarterbacks i'd rather have that
are available
the mustache he looks great i mean this
guy is what
fifth uh or at least top five in
completion percentage
he's giving you 20 plus points in two
straight games he's got the dolphins
this week his schedule is
really good over the next month i
believe he's got miami then he's got the
bengals the lions the texans are in
there as well
brian tannehill i looked at espn's
ownership percentage and i'm thinking
this guy's riding dangerfield no respect
at all
second half of last year one of the best
quarterbacks in fantasy football so far
this year he's been tremendous
had 26.7 last week almost 20 in the
opener
he's looked great man you get away from
adam gase and look what's happening
tannehill's the guy that i would add joe
burrow is another player i love the way
this kid looks he's got that it factor
and cincinnati is going to be playing
from behind a lot this year so
derek carr is certainly worth a look i'm
not giving up on brady or breeze just
yet though to pick up dc
plus they've got new england this week
and that's not a great matchup
all right fabs um tell me what else
you're up to uh i i give you the floor i
know you got a lot going on i want to
make sure that uh
we we get everything out where everybody
can find you
yeah so uh fi.com fantasy you can find
stardom in situm the one the only the
original there every wednesday my player
rankings also
at si.com fantasy they come out every
wednesday as well
my show and by the way rich you know
we've been friends for a long time my
fantasy dirt on siriusxm fantasy sports
radio 8 pm eastern to 10 p.m eastern
i really used a lot of inspiration from
you for that because you were a guy
who was in the sports world espn moving
on to the nfl network and now you're
doing entertainment and i love the fact
that you mixed in sports
with celebrities and i do that on my
show too i've actually had a lot of
celebrities on my show that you've had
on your show
like jeff garland for example and and
you've been an inspiration for that so i
really want to say thank you
for that and i hope people will tune in
because the show is going to give you a
mix of
great fantasy football advice with
myself mike dempsey and bob harris but
we also bring in the celebrities okay
jerry o'connell's been on a couple of
times
uh over the course of the season he's
been great we bring in a lot of
celebrities who love fantasy football
jerry cantrell our pal from alison
mckagan i mean i've had tommy leon from
motley crew
joe buck and and all of this rich is
because
uh you had a vision that i really liked
and i followed it
and this is what i wanted to do on
siriusxm bring in
my expertise in fantasy football with
the celebrity aspect of things
and i hope people will check it out also
you can check me out uh
on westwood one every single weekend on
the nfl fantasy forecast
with jason horowitz uh i miss you i miss
network but i'm still out there all over
the place well again
fabs you've got you've got some um first
of all thank you and congrats on
everything that's going on
uh you have some some sway over um
over cantrell and and that league that
we're in together
can you help correct the standings
please because it says
we're one and one we're really two and
oh cause
jerry forfeited the win over
us five days before actually getting it
when he texted me saying that he had no
chance against us
and i take that as a win and it
it seems like he actually did in fact
play the fantasy week
and lost we lost to him so can we get
that fixed unless you want to start a
new segment with him on your show called
bitching and moaning which might be a
great new album
for alice in chains based on his fantasy
complaint
but i will say this will you please you
and jerry are
two of the hall of fame fantasy football
whiners
when it comes to trying to
reverse jinx an outcome and i do it too
but you guys are two of the best no
excuse me excuse me
fabs i know i slagged you in your
introduction at the pro
i will not let that sound we don't we
don't we don't send texts like we have
no shot
this thing is over he's like days ahead
of time
he did on tuesday yeah on tuesday
literally we have no shot against you i
screen grabbed it i put it on twitter
come on
i saw it uh that that sounds like
cantrell man he does it with me too
he loves to throw up that like reverse
jinx out there
and then if he ends up winning well man
geez
i mean i was lucky to beat you guys i
didn't think i had a chance that that's
jc's whole mo man
fabs thanks for the the two cents
appreciate it all right my friend thank
you michael fabiano
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here